there is no end in sight when it comes
to gun violence in chicago just this
weekend 60 people were shot and 11 of
those victims were under the age of 18.
now joe biden will tell you that he
cares about the kids when it comes to
covet after all that's why he's pushing
mass and vaccinations in schools but
just this year more kids have been shot
in chicago alone then have died of covet
in the whole country according to the
chicago pd at least 261 kids have been
shot in chicago this year now compare
that to 214 covert related deaths the
life of every child is important and
each death is a tragedy no matter how
they died so why does it feel like joe
biden is only frustrated about covet
joining me now is the founder of black
guns matter my surrey
uh maj uh this is a topic that is near
and dear to my heart your heart
why is it
any interest from the president of the
united states on this issue i mean he
talks about vaccination he talks about
mass he talks about
lockdowns and keeping people safe
but the kids that are being shot every
single day not a word
well because joe biden doesn't care
about black people
it's not it's not complicated he spent
most of his political career locking
black people up um joe biden even when
he was famously running to be the you
know vice president you know
said obama you know he's one of the
clean ones joe biden has
zero interest um this facade you know
he's he's he's a part of that cabal he's
that he's down he's down with the
opposite team and i think that in
essence um he's just showing us exactly
who he is he's shown us for half half a
century but i think he's being more more
brazen with it you saw a few days ago
where he literally told the american
people that you know i'm getting tired
of not being as much of a tyrant as i
want to be when he talks about our
patience is wearing thin so this is this
is par for the course for for joe biden
and not even just joe biden you got to
look at lori lightfoot over in chicago
you got all these young people dying
this is the same person that said you
know it was all last year with the fake
woke you know we're gonna defund the
police we need all of this covet money
that she just reallocated right into the
police department but nothing for
developing the communities that are
impacted by this negligence in regards
to you know irresponsible gun ownership
so this is par for the course for
democrats and the simple answer is joe
biden doesn't care about black people
especially the black people and youth in
chicago
so then this is where it gets troubling
for me because it's not just joe biden
it's the whole democratic party they
have been complete failures when it
comes to the community you got kim fox
you got the judges there the city
council all democrats they run it but
then i look at my republican brothers
and sisters and i say well you know the
democrats are this bad
if they're this bad why can't you beat
them i mean it's just as simple these
people are crying out for help and
they're willing to accept anybody that
is provoking change and liberty and
choosing life over anything so why can't
you beat these bad candidates
they can't beat the bad candidates
because there's still a lot of and again
i'm going to say the truth and i don't
want to offend but some people are going
to be offended by this the reality is a
lot of the old guard on the right side
on the republican side on our
libertarian side
they don't want to go into places that
are are scary or where the other are
others are you have candidates like kim
klasik that ran out in baltimore raised
eight million dollars by telling the
truth about what was happening in that
democratically rand city of baltimore
you have other people attacking her
saying that she shouldn't run in places
that are unwinnable this is the
mentality that
right
like america was unwinnable when we went
up against the british folks you know
when when people were fighting from
captivity during enslavement in america
harriet tubman was fighting an
unwinnable fight you know john f kennedy
asking the american people at that time
to not you know worry about just what
their country can do for them but what
they can do for their country that was
unwinnable this is the this is the
mentality that we've allowed to fester
on the right you know and a lot of that
in these democratically ran cities i
understand it i just disagree with it
it's because of the fact that we accept
that well it's been this way for this
long if if the founding fathers to this
nation would have accepted it that way
we'd be speaking french right now so the
reality is um you know it's it's a it's
a victim and and you know defeatist
mentality that we on the right have to
stop if we want to save the republic
if you can't sell freedom and liberty
then maybe you shouldn't be in the fight
brother so thank you so much for being
on the program i know you're doing it
every day working to win back our
communities i appreciate you coming on
the program hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else